so what keeps coming up for me lately is
this question this issue related to the
upper echelon of human intimacy what
does it mean to really know there is
this desire for the intersubjective
there is this desire in us for closeness
with those we loved to know another
completely right but can this ever be
possible can you ever truly know and the
challenge thus far has been one we've
attempted to solve with crude tools
right from early cave paintings to
portray our interior tea to the
beginning of writing and reading and
speaking writing coding the contents of
our mind into a symbolic structure of
technology that's wireless that could
send meaning from one mind to another
but like a game of telephone a lot was
lost in translation right always has
been the case by the time you convey
meaning to someone else hey it's been
filtered and colored by their prejudices
and biases and errors in the
transcription data for a lack of a
better word when we lack the capacity to
articulate how we feel the point is we
want to know another and to be known
fully by another and it's very very
difficult human beings I think aspire to
a level of fidelity to a kind of
resolution in our capacity to convey
meanings so that we can finally get
arrived at a place where we become
essentially telepathic beings this is a
it's a way station that we're currently
on as we
continue to develop new modalities to
awaken the intersubjective so what
current mediums exist for sharing
meetings what is the intermediary that
we can turn to in the meantime when we
want to feel intimacy with another
person in relationship
I think music I think poetry I think a
melody can be an intermediary that
brings two minds together into sharing
communion cosmic communion to have a
common experience together where you two
become one right when you enter a
cosmology of to a universe shaped like a
heart
or two people live
[Music]
I think maybe
so I guess until we develop better and
better communications technology item I
my advice and suggestion to all of you
out there all of you creatives and you
frustrated poets like seek out new tools
and new modalities to share your
insights find new ways alkalis new
virtual realities new augmented reality
is new toolkits for the mind so that we
can hopefully some time reach a state
where we can truly become one and know
each other fully